you know I like durian durian is a great
guy
91 he pushed Haney 92 we won it was like
227 pounds 90 Toria he was tremendous
that picture but when he started tearing
things I didn't agree with the judges
that he should have won you know just my
opinion I thought those years could flex
of one good Shan have one quick Kevin
have one yeah I I could have seen that
you know but I wasn't a judge I don't
tell the judges who to vote for I tell
them how the judge meaning apply the
rules but I don't tell them who the
judge who to vote for yeah Sean I mean
when you look at Sean's physique you
know weaknesses yeah well what Sean's
weakness it wasn't quite as tall as the
other fellows probably could award his
trunks a little bit higher so we didn't
see him as long wasted you know you
created an optical illusion you look at
the guys back on of time how much bigger
the trunks were now they're basically
wearing bikinis if your trunks are
higher you don't seem as long wasted
where they say always sky-high lats well
if his trunks were you know an inch
below his bellybutton throughs instead
of six inches it's all an optical
illusion and that's why I think Sean was
unhappy you know people would say to me
why do you let him speak why do you let
him knock you why do you let him say
things at the press conference and I
would always say Sean may say a hundred
things 99 maybe idiotic or annoy me but
he may say one thing that's good and
that's what you have to do when you're
in charge and that's something that
nobody sees and let's look at another
thing no matter who the president is
half the people hate them okay if you're
in charge and you let people have
freedom to speak and speak their minds
and write anything they want and say
anything they want publicly privately
you're gonna get knocked once you come
out from the crowd and you're up here
your target mm-hmm if you don't want to
be a target then don't do it
you know I understood that from the
beginning and it was like
I understood that of the phrase
publicity good or bad as long as they
spell my name right long you put about
the things you mention the contest you
mention this your pension that what is
my job not to Pat myself on the back my
job is to promote good contests I I
continue to promote good contests and
make money I continue to promote
contests and build a sport if I had lost
money and gone away what would happen to
pro bodybuilding if I didn't take that
risk and use my own money yeah people
criticize you I'm sure all the time yeah
do you care no you enjoy what you're
doing actually I learned a lot I gotta
say I learn a lot because the way I look
at it is mike and my heavy duty critics
who are competitors they're the best
consultants i'll have because they
identify my weakness more than my peers
ever will and that's how you get better
it's the best consultants cheapest
consultants because you don't pay for it
they just criticize you yeah
[Music]